استوديو ينضم الينا استشاري جراحه العظام
دكتور عاصم خدوم دكتور يسعد صباحك شكرا
هذه بينتكسرت اي مهاره والله سبحانه
وتعالى طبعا بعد توفيق تبان على ان نتائج
وشكرا جزيلا هذا الاصدار
طيب دكتور عمليه يوم واحد لتبديل مفصل
الركبه اكثر طيب اول شيء خشونه الركبه
اتكلم عنها خشونه الركبه هو للاسف الشديد
مرض موجود بشكل كبير في طبعا له اسباب
وراثيه في اسباب تتعلق بزياده الوزن
عصابات قديمه في الركبه العلاج ما هو
دائما يكون تبديل نفس الرقم هذا العلاج
النهائي اذا كانت الخشونه جدا جدا شديده
نقطه التبديل هنا الان ااا تقليديه ان
الناس طبعا او شائع انه هذه عمليه خطيره
وصعبه ونسبه نجاحها ما هي عاليه طبعا مع
التقنيات الحديثه في خلال اخر خمسه او
عشره سنوات صرنا نسميها عمليات اليوم
الواحد والتاهيل السريع بمعنى ان المريض
يدخل يسوي العمليه ممكن يخرج في نفس اليوم
ويجلس 24 ساعه في المستشفى
بعد العمليه مباشره بعد ساعات جلوسه في
المستشفى يكون 24 ساعه طبعا في مرض يكون
عندهم مشاكل صحيه همم اخرى غير الركبه
مثلا مشاكل في القلب او غير هذا هيحتاج
همم انه يجلس اكثر من 24 ساعه
صحيح مده العمليه 45 دقيقه تقريبا همم همم
ليش هذا الشيء صار انه الحمد لله تطورت
الجراحه بشكل مره كبير
وانواع المفاصل المستخدمه تطورت بشكل كبير
فخطوات العمليه صارت اقل طب بروتوكول
عمليه تحرير الاربطه قليل همم العضلات
كذلك
على العضلات بشكل جدا كبير المحافظه على
الانسجه المحيطه بالركبه حتى تحرير
الاربطه ما يكون بشكل همم واسع يكون فقط
دقيق عشان المريض يشعر برقبه مستقره همم
من بعد ساعات من بعد العمليه طيب دكتور
الا اما هذه العمليه ترتبط بالبنيه
الجسديه للمريض قوه عضلاته
مهم لانه في بعض المرضى بسبب الخوف من
العمليه ههه يكون بتاجيل العمليه سنين
وسنين المشكله التاجير العمليه اذا كانت
الخشونه شديده يصير عندك العضلات فيها
الضمور فانا احيانا يقول لي متضايع في
العياده طيب يعني احنا ممكن نسوي تبديل بس
اذا لم يوجد عضلات سبب ضمور ها بالتالي
يكون التاهيل جدا صعب ولذلك
انا نصيحتي للمرضى انه اذا كانت الخشونه
عندك شديده ووجدت الاستشاري المختص ونصحك
بالعمليه
فلابد انك تختار الوقت المناسب اللي هو
تكون الصحه ما زال جيده العضلات ما زال
جيده والطبيب طبعا الماهر طيب كل مريض
يخاف من الالم سمعت انه العمليه المها
قليله اقل كثير من الضحيه التقليديه طبعا
ليش هذا الشيء صار بسبب انه همم اول شيء
لمده العمليه الجراحيه قصيره همم النزيف
داخل العمليه جدا محدود همم البروتوكولات
تطوير الالم صارت همم يعني تغيرت بشكل مره
كبير خلال اخر خمس سنوات طيب دكتور ما هي
الحالات التي تستلزم تغيير مفاصل الركبه
او تبديل المفاصل الركبه هل كل الحالات
يعني تنفعها هذه العمليه
فقط الحالات اللي تكون الخشونه فيها جدا
جدا همم شديده
طيب دكتور بالنسبه للعمل للناس الي اجروا
قبلا عمليه تقليديه للركبه يمكن اجرائها
لهذه العمليه ايضا طبعا اذا كانت اجره
العمليه مثلا وكانت ناجحه لما يحتاج انه
يعيدها لكن اذا لا سمح الله فشلت ممكن
تكون لها اعاده ان شاء الله ما ترسل اي من
العمليات يا رب شكرا جزيلا دكتور نتمنى
السلامه